how are you doing today sir
stephen how are you man i'm good uh you
won't remember this but we actually
spoke at the nine days after party at
sundance
i do remember this vividly yeah i was
going to say before kova destroyed
everything
i know it was like literally the the few
weeks away from
from the world of being ablaze no i
remember very well how are you
i'm doing excellent listen congrats on
this movie um
i want i want to i have a one important
question i think i want to start with
um what exactly did your dad put in the
water in your household
to get your entire family to be such
talented actors
um just just a lot of alcohol
just a lot there's a lot of activity in
the in the
no i don't i don't know i really don't
know like
if there's something in the water um um
maybe it's uh
maybe it's in the jeans um maybe it's
passed along that way i'm not entirely
sure it's
it's bizarre to me but um i guess i mean
it's also like it's not so uncommon for
family
professions in other professions right i
feel like it's
it's it's something and you know i we
grew up in a very kind of animated
loud household that that
being able to um perform around the
dinner table was
i guess kind of important and it was
important to make people laugh
and and to have fun and maybe that
environment maybe inspires
inspires the kids to uh to follow down
the you know their
their father's footstep i'm not sure
it's it's it's
it's still a little bit surprising to me
as i know it is to my father
who expect he had he didn't expect any
of his kids to be actors and
now like all of them are so listen
i'm super i'm very on on board with all
of you guys acting because i really
enjoy the work
um jumping into this the reason i get to
talk to you today um
what was it about i mean it's a little
generic but what was it about the
material
and this character that said i i really
want to be involved in this
you know it was just one of those things
it was you know i think it was like i
read it right around christmas and
it was a script that was floating around
and and um
um i got it and you know they said that
they
potentially was interested in me for the
role of willard and
and i read it and as soon as i read the
story i was like oh man this is
this is uh this is something else it's
an amazing amazing
depiction of a time and a place and
and and what you know what really
i think desperate people do in order to
try to save themselves or their loved
ones
i thought it was riveting and this kind
of you know
southern gothic and tone thriller really
and
uh and as soon as i read it i was like
man i don't know if
if if a boy from sweden
can can can can do this and pull this
off and and fit into this world that
feels
so american you know
like post world war ii you know rural
america
it it felt um uh it felt uh
it was really intimidating and i
auditioned for it and i was like man i
don't know
what i'm doing here early like i hope
that that tony antonio campos likes it
i was also a really big fan of tony and
his film before
you know i i was blown away by simon
killer in one of his
earlier films and i just think he's a
terrific filmmaker and i've met him
before as well so
so yeah and then he was like okay try
this and i read for it again
and then ultimately he you know gave his
trust in me
um which was uh like honestly even after
i booked the
film um i was like i don't know if i can
pull this off so it was like
this kind of wonderful experience of
of being afraid and and and insecure
but also inspired and motivated at the
same time and i think like
all of those emotions are always like uh
they usually
you know at least you know gets you to
to a place where you might surprise
yourself and and and
and and that was kind of my way into it
and
and and just the experience of it all
was amazing
i already got to go i'm gonna say
congrats on the movie
i hope you're still doing northman are
you
no unfortunately not like it was it's
it's been a scheduling
nightmare during covet so so
oh yeah it is what it is it's a big
shame you know edgars is uh
one of the great filmmakers out there
and working with my brother i don't want
to talk about it it's going to make me
burst into tears
but i understand listen have a great day
um congrats on everything good to see
you man